there are many shows we remember fondly
from our childhoods from the adventures
of the teenage mutant ninja turtles to
the saturday morning cartoons of the
flintstones or the jetsons but arguably
the most famous of these cartoons is
spongebob squarepants
a show about an optimistic sea sponge
and his daily life throughout his city
of bikini bottom we all know the same
spongebob squarepants in some way or
some form his popularity translated to a
lot of merchandise from plushes to
lunchboxes and phone cases spongebob is
a staple of childhood and modern day
culture while the scp foundation's world
is one where monsters roam and anomalous
events affect millions spongebob and his
merchandise is also popular within this
universe the scp foundation is most well
known for its protection of normalcy and
from the most extreme and dangerous
threats anomalies such as scp-17
the inter-dimensional site-13
scp-001 when daybreaks or scp-682 the
humanity-hating hard to destroy reptile
these scps pose a direct obvious threat
to the people of the scp universe a lot
of these anomalies have object classes
that clearly state the danger level
along with their level of containment
difficulty ketter apollyon euclid and
more safe class anomalies are not
commonly thought of as dangerous but
what about those safe class anomalies
that were specifically made to be
inconspicuously dangerous to humankind
today we take a deep dive into one such
anomaly and we don't mean scuba diving
or
do we
anyhow here's a look at
scp-1808 also known as the spongebob
watches its containment procedures are
almost too simple but given it's a safe
class anomaly it's all about the
difficulty of putting it in a box and
keeping it there more than being about
its danger level there are six instances
of scp-1808
and all are kept in standard safe class
anomaly storage lockers in safe wing c
at site-25 this is similar to the
containment procedures of scp-662
the butler's handbell which is also a
relatively safe anomaly all things
considered the containment procedures
also mentioned that all testing outside
of monitored environments is expressly
prohibited it begs the question if this
safe class anomaly can be kept in simple
storage lockers why is there such a
strict mandate against testing what
potential danger could
scp-1808 pose that these restrictions
are placed on it well to properly answer
all of your amazingly inquisitive
questions we need to look back on the
story of how scp-1808
came into the foundation's possession to
begin with in early april of 2004 the
foundation was alerted to an ongoing
anomalous item auction from the
anomalous group of interest marshall
carter and dark anomalous groups of
interest within the scp foundation's
universe are all but rare from the
malicious chaos insurgency that works to
harm the foundation by utilizing
anomalies as weapons to scp-610 which
uses yaldeboth worshiping sarkic cults
that work to bring humankind back to a
primal way of living these groups are
known for their use of the anomalous for
executing their plans and as we've seen
time and time again on this channel by
pretty much any means they deem
necessary let's just say there are not
many boundaries set or
none let's go no boundaries
moving on when it comes to marshall
carter and dark however they are a bit
different from these groups instead of
calling upon the starfish god like the
fithists or rebuilding the god of
technology meccan like the church of the
broken god marshall carter and dark have
one motive prophet this group is solely
dedicated to selling and profiting from
the anomalous whether it be through
selling to the highest one percent of
the one percent or contracting their
anomalies out to other anomalous
organizations for high payments marshall
carter and dark is in the world of
leveraging the anomalous for money and
as much money as possible the scp
foundation normally has a somewhat
cordial relationship with marshall
carter and dark sometimes even
purchasing anomalies from the group for
containment purposes however marshall
carter and dark often overstep these
bound
boundaries causing the scp foundation to
have to intervene and steal anomalies
from them the story of
scp-1808 is one of these times the
foundation had to step in an agent of
mobile task force etta ii buyer beware
agent rosser was working covertly within
the ranks of marshall carter and dark
attaining information that may be needed
for the scp foundation's containment
efforts agent rosser was of course under
strict protocols set forward by the scp
foundation he was to keep them updated
with any movements marshall carter and
dark may be making noting any potential
anomalies that may need containing and
as always making sure to be checking in
every day on april 4th agent rosser
failed to do his required check-in and
the foundation immediately deployed
other buyer beware mtf agents to his
last known location a marshall carter
and dark auction house the raid
commenced and the scp foundation having
some of the most highly trained and
sophisticated soldiers and agents in the
world swiftly took the upper hand
restraining and apprehending members of
marshall carter and dark and their
potential buyers a large-scale search
then commenced for agent rosser within
the auction house where he was found
seated behind a curtain with all six
instances of
scp-1808 attached to his body one on
each of his wrists and ankles and two
fastened together around his neck agent
rosser was found in a state that could
only be described as pure torment he was
unrecognizable the bones of his fingers
and toes were so elongated they circled
back onto themselves the skin of his
hands and feet were torn to shreds from
the force of whatever was pulling at
them the foundation issued boots agent
rosser wore were ripped as well to make
way for the bones and possibly most
ghastly of all his teeth had grown out
of his mouth
tearing the skin of his cheeks and jaw
could it be that these simple spongebob
watches were the cause of his torture
there were no other obvious threats
observed that could possibly be the
cause of these changes to his body this
made the foundation suspicious and
worried what else could be in store for
them the scp-1808 file described the
anomaly as a set of six yellow plastic
wrist watches these watches are
patterned with green dots scattered
along the watch body along with images
of the famous cartoon character
spongebob squarepants the first
anomalous property of scp-1808
is that no matter what mechanical or
electronic parts are removed the watch
still operates as if it's perfectly
intact the most dangerous part of
scp-1808 is when it's placed on a person
or animal as long as the wearer has
limbs and phalanx bones
scp-1808's main anomalous property will
affect them once put on
scp-1808 cannot be removed unless the
person who put it on decides to take it
off once placed those wearing
scp-1808 will hear a chime of
spongebob's famous or infamous chuckle
every 15 minutes if hearing that wasn't
suffering enough
scp-1808's anomalous property will now
begin to affect the wearer after the
laugh is heard the bones in whatever
hand the person is wearing
scp-1808 will begin to grow in length
every 15 minutes as long as
scp-1808 is worn these bones will extend
about six centimeters until the watch is
removed the skin around the bones does
not grow so once they get long enough
the bones will tear through and rip the
skin to continue growing while there is
no blood loss once this happens those
who have worn
scp-1808 describe the growing as
immensely painful these changes do not
have to be permanent should the person
that placed it on the poor soul who has
to suffer these consequences feel a bit
of mercy they can retract the adjustment
knob of the watch and rotate it
counterclockwise upon doing this the
bones will begin to shrink back to their
original size and the ripped and torn
skin will anomalously heal back to its
normal state as if
scp-1808 never affected it while the
physical harm that scp-18 steroid
inflicts on its victims can be reversed
the memory of the pain and torment the
victims went through will be fully
remembered potentially causing further
psychological torment even when the
watches are removed the item's
description also includes the terrifying
note that two instances of
scp-1808 can be placed around a
subject's neck and instead of
lengthening any bones in the neck it
will instead mercilessly cause the
victim's teeth to grow in the case of
agent rosser we now know the suffering
he was going through during his time as
a spy for the scp foundation
yikes the potential danger these watches
can pose if in the wrong hands no pun
intended of course can be devastating
what if an authoritarian government
purchased these anomalies the torture
scp-1808 inflicts upon its victims could
easily be used to squeeze information
out of a person of interest same goes
for the chaos insurgency who could use
these anomalies to attack the scp
foundation and gain classified
information only someone like a member
of the overseer command would know these
anomalies had to be contained the
foundation quickly restrained the
marshall carter and dark agent
inflicting this horrible torture on
agent rosser and forced him to return
agent rosser's deformities back to
normal and hand over the watches
questions circled in the foundation's
minds why was there no blood despite the
amount of damage on agent rosser's skin
and why did the marshall carter and dark
agents do this to him in the first place
a foundation doctor conducted an
interview with agent rosser with hopes
to figure it all out the doctor began
with a simple statement kindly summarize
the events leading up to your abduction
rosser answered there was nothing crazy
about my abduction i went to sleep in my
flat and woke up tied to a table maybe i
was drugged but i'm not sure this
confused the doctor normally when an
undercover scp foundation agent is
discovered they are not treated with the
relative kindness agent rosser was shown
these groups especially those such as
marshall carter and dark normally want
information and will take that by any
means necessary the doctor continues
with his questioning how did marshall
carter and doc come to discover your
identity as a foundation field agent
ross or chuckles
i was never compromised as an agent you
see i don't think they were even aware i
was foundation if they were they would
have called off the auction and gotten
their goods the hell out of there he
goes on to say that he didn't even tell
his friends or family any details that
would have made them suspicious of his
rank in the foundation once again the
doctor was extremely confused by this
move on marshall carter and dark's part
if they didn't know agent rosser was of
the scp foundation why did they torture
him the doctor asks this question to
agent rosser if your identity wasn't
compromised why were you abducted and
tortured agent rosser responds i think
it was quality assurance testing the
product making sure it worked
experimenting with it and if the raid
hadn't happened it would have put me on
stage and demonstrated it like the scp
foundation marshall carter and dark are
more than willing to test out these
anomalies on unwilling subjects perhaps
they see their employees like the scp
foundation sees the d-class personnel at
least the d-class personnel are death
row inmates they're people who committed
heinous crimes whereas agent rosser and
his co-workers were innocent people
trying to make a living we see how
brutal the world of a prophet driven
anomalous group could be with what
happened to agent rosser and one could
only imagine the horrifying torment the
former employees of marshall carter and
dark may have went through under this
so-called quality assurance agent rosser
continued with his story he described
the events leading up to the watches
being placed on him he drowsily awoke in
the dark room strapped to a table he
recognized the room he was in as the
basement he looked to his left and then
his right when his stomach dropped he
wasn't the only one down there next to
him were people he recognized as his
coworkers strapped to tables like him
after this realization his shock turned
to fear as senior members of marshall
carter and dark entered the room we are
downsizing one of them said to the
helpless employees they were going to
use them as guinea pigs for their
twisted testing of their products agent
rosser gets distracted describing how
much he used to enjoy the spongebob
squarepants television show he watched
it recently and found it funny but now
all he could think of is that laugh
every 15 minutes that laughs signified
more torture more torment that he had to
be put through now he can't imagine
watching the show without thinking of
the torment
scp-1808 and marshall carter and dark
put him through while the physical scars
are gone the mental ones still awfully
remain the doctor interviewing him
requests that agent rosser stays on the
topic of scp-1808
the agent apologizes and continues first
they just strapped the watches to my
wrists and ankles and waited after they
were sure the things went off every 15
minutes they started twisting the little
knobs he describes that he knew he was
definitely being tested on the marshall
carter and dark senior staff were
observing these tests the entire time
and even participated the experimenters
would twist the knobs mercilessly until
the bones in his hands and feet tore
free of the skin and hit the walls of
the basement only for them to crank them
back and forth and begin the process all
over again you can only imagine how many
times they did this to the agent for no
other purpose but quality assurance
agents of the scp foundation are trained
to withstand awful torture so that no
confidential or important information is
revealed to other groups of interest or
the public agent rosser being trained by
the foundation would know this training
he attempted to use his training methods
to resist the torture but sadly it
wasn't enough agent rosser states the
pain was from the inside the tips of my
fingers were worn off and peeled back
like an old pair of gloves he was one of
the lucky ones though the people chained
to the tables in the same room he was in
didn't survive whatever twisted torture
they went through at the hands of
marshall carter and dark the doctor
realizes that part of agent roster's
story is being overlooked in the states
when you were discovered tours of arches
had been joined together and fastened
around your neck agent rosser is silent
this was clearly the most horrifying
part of the entire ordeal for him his
silence persists for another minute and
the doctor calls his name agent rosser
rosser shakely begins apparently the
marshall carter and dark senior staff
weren't impressed with the effects of
scp-1808
despite the clear signs of pain and
anguish from agent rosser they thought
it needed to be improved for a higher
sale price one of them suggested placing
two of the watches around his throat
roster describes how his teeth began to
grow my my teeth started getting longer
like my fingers and toes but they didn't
go straight it went off in different
directions some went inside rosser
explains that all he could hear every
time his teeth grew was that infamous
spongebob laugh he goes on to tell the
doctor that this torture impressed the
senior staff of marshall carter and dark
enough to continue with the sail the
memory of this makes agent rosser ill
and he vomits before he can even finish
the thought the doctor allows agent
rosser to be dismissed hopefully he was
provided with some class a amnestics to
forget this whole ordeal the foundation
didn't contain
scp-3000 and harvest the y-909 compound
for nothing the scp-1808 file also
includes a recovered auction catalog
that marshall carter and dark would have
used to describe
to potential buyers the description goes
on to read these watches are the only
products in existence with such uncanny
abilities and businesses or individuals
wishing to carry out quick efficient and
mess-free interrogations would be remiss
in missing this once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to acquire them as would our
patrons with tastes for intimate
sessions of impassioned discomfort the
starting bid on scp-1808
only 14
600 pounds
marshall carter and dark had no issues
selling these watches to those who
wanted to inflict awful torture on their
unwilling and unknowing victims and we
thought the scp foundation was willing
to stop moral boundaries all it took was
a little motivation for profits and
marshall carter and dark were
shamelessly off to the races for a few
rather normal looking spongebob themed
watches
scp-1808 is truly a terrifying anomaly
thanks to agent rosser's sacrifice they
are no longer on wrists and necks and
are now in shall we say better hands
with the foundation in the case of
marshall carter and dark they suspended
their morality to the point of testing
the anomaly on their own employees i
guess this goes to show that profits
over people is more than just a scary
concept even in the world of the scp
foundation now go check out how does the
scp foundation actually make money and
scp-738 the devil's deal for more on
anomalous business transactions that
might just cost you more than you can
bargain for